you can't keep Americans down born of
rebellion and revolution we are ready to
fight it's in our DNA we're ready to
fight the virus ready to fight to get
back to work and ready to fight to
reopen our country in a safe and
strategic way we get it we're not stupid
we know to wash our hands wear a mask
and keep our distance we know to look
for signs of the virus we look to
protect the vulnerable
we appreciate the numbers need to be
contained as we go through the three
phases of reopening we know the virus
can come back and we will be ever
vigilant to make sure a complete
reopening is dependent upon the data now
we've been sheltered in place for weeks
and we are not children we are capable
of using our god-given common sense to
protect ourselves and others but there
has to be a balance between physical
safety and economic survival more and
more people becoming unemployed 22
million so far people watch their
savings their livelihood and their
dreams disappear for some there will
simply be no business to rebuild for
others there will be no coming back from
the depths of depression alcohol or drug
abuse cancelled elective surgeries
prolonged enormous physical pain
suffering and further stress and
depression all the wild Navy ships
turned into hospitals said that the
requests of panicked governor's remained
virtually empty on both coasts and yet
some continued to think the nanny state
is the answer and yet today data
suggests the virus is far less deadly
than thought that percentage estimates
of death are statistically exaggerated
enough inflated numbers enough of the
lockdown
the Declaration of Independence gives us
the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
included is the right to survive live
freely and care for our families it does
not give governor's the right to impose
nanny states reduce liberties and
enlarge government power the certainly
government has the authority to protect
public health during a pandemic but that
power cannot be used to nullify
constitutional rights including the
right of peaceful protest when civil
liberties are at stake enough of these
small-time politicians using this
pandemic to flex their pathetic muscles
in order to gain attention like
ticketing citizens for attending driving
church services on church property in
their own cars like a resting and
handcuffing of father in front of his
children for playing catch outdoors like
prohibiting citizens the right to
purchase firearms take michigan governor
Gretchen Whitmer auditioning to be the
woman VP candidate on Democrat Joe
Biden's presidential ticket she issues
nonsensical absurd guidelines certainly
capable of attracting national attention
but laughable were the situation not so
deadly serious her actions both
overbearing discriminatory and
point-blank unconstitutional now
governor Gretchen says it's okay in her
feet to Michigan to buy alcohol and
lottery tickets
she keeps abortion clinics open to get
an abortion but don't you dare even
think about going to church and she must
be talking as she decreased Herman hi
that you can buy weed but you can't buy
grass seed or vegetable seed but you're
just stay in your home but you don't you
dare think about buying paint to fix it
up Gretchen ruled home-improvement
stores could stay open but
they had to close those aisles that had
paint flooring and outdoor gardening
sections and when our Michigan
constituents came out of their homes to
protest and exercise their civil
liberties she doubles down and she
threatens to extend the stay of home
orders Gretchen your VP audition ain't
going so well and then you have New
Jersey Governor Phil Murphy he can't
explain why he allowed selling beer
liquor and weed to remain open as
essential businesses but sought to
punish churches and synagogues from
providing religious freedom and in
response to Fox News's Tucker Carlson's
questions about the Bill of Rights and
his interference with religious freedoms
he said quote he wasn't thinking about
the Bill of Rights and says it's above
his pay grade above your pay grade
you forgot the Constitution did you
forget you took an oath to uphold it no
more
Americans won't accept their rights
being trampled on no more of this
one-size-fits-all mentality 22 million
jobs lost so far and now Washington has
run out of money to pay for the small
business loan program layoffs are the
predictable outcome from that one
American sheltered in their homes have
been patiently watching this unfold have
seen the data and the facts changed from
day to day
first there were 2.2 million who were
supposed to die in the United States and
then it was a million then it was
500,000 then 250,000 and supposedly
mitigation was already taken into
account in those numbers but the models
folks are just plain wrong and today a
potentially lower death rate and we
understand there are still many sick and
dying and density and hot spots are to
be treated differently but what about
the rest of us we want to go back to
work feed our families
and as the governors sit there and
pontificate we are the ones experiencing
the reality that for every percentage
drop in employment there are five to ten
thousand deaths occurring depression
suicide domestic violence child abuse
resurgence of alcoholism drug addiction
loss of hope battered women locked at
home with their abusers abused children
not being identified or protected
because they cannot go to school I'll
wear my mask my gloves and I'll keep my
distance and I'll do the testing whether
to determine if I have Kovan or whether
I have the antibody but don't you even
think about tracing or tracking or
giving me a card it ain't happening your
models are out of control
the economy is out of control China is
the one that's out of control we're not
going to let you destroy this country or
our way of life
we've worked too hard and we fought too
long to lose it to a woman that's what I
said Oh whoo and virus that China knew
about openly lied about said it couldn't
be transmitted from human to human and
intentionally protected Chinese citizens
from the virus but allowed that virus to
be released putting the rest of the
world at risk you want to control people
you politicians want to flex your
muscles we'll start working on how
you're going to punish ostracize
alienate and financially sanction and
make China accountable for what they did
to us and the rest of the world but keep
your damn hands off us and do something
about what got us into this mess in the
first place
that's my open